stephanie's with us in tampa florida hi
stephanie
welcome to the ramsay show thank you
dave hi ken how are you guys doing
great how can we help um well
um i i will just get right to it um i am
about 45 000 in debt
um some of that is over to the irs
um some of it is in collections most of
it is student loans
and then the other half is through
credit cards
with two of them being with a credit i
think consolidation company
so clearly i'm overwhelmed
because i am self-employed i work from
home
but my income per month is around 700
maybe a little bit more if i'm lucky so
um i do
have a thousand dollars put aside i did
read your book
a few months ago and that's done thanks
to a car
that i that i had sold um and
but with the money i make now i'm just
like
wondering like stephanie you're starving
to death
seven hundred dollars a month you're
living way below the poverty level
yes but there is a reason for that i i
do live with my parents
um i i love living with my
fiance how old are you before
i'm training why don't you get a job
i'm actually doing that right now i
actually have an interview later this
afternoon
which i hope if everything goes well
i'll get it and i'll be making
double than what i am now with more
hours
more than that fourteen hundred
no no no no it would be like right now
my hours aren't
that much um it's i would say maybe
it's like 20 hours a week stephanie what
are you applying to do
and what is it that you really want to
do answer those two questions
so what i'm trying to do is um
it's a i guess an administrative
assistant
um it's uh like a scheduler
which would make about 20
okay um what i wanted to do and the
reason why i'm actually living with my
parents now
is that i was actually supposed to move
to japan for a teaching job
phone's cutting teaching and out can you
speak directly into your phone please
yes is this better yes ma'am um yeah so
um where did i leave off that you
couldn't hear me what you really want to
do what's it
what's the big goal for you
professionally what do you want to do
so i really want to teach
and um i actually was supposed to go to
japan
to do that job my fiance is already
there
but thanks to the pandemic i i wasn't
able to go before the borders closed
but you're qualified to teach here in
the us presumably
um the my degree isn't in teaching it's
something that i found out after i
graduated that i wanted to do
so right now i i wouldn't have the
qualifications each year
okay well you got to get yourself stable
financially and you're living with your
parents so
obviously that allows you to keep your
expenses low but you got to work the
debt snowball you just read dave's book
you got your thousand dollars and now
this is about getting hired and this is
two and three jobs i mean you're young
enough
uh you're not married this is no life at
all you're working
like absolute like a maniac and then
you're knocking this stuff out you can
actually do this
but you're gonna have to go at it like
you've never gone at anything in your
life
and as you're doing that you're gonna
get stable and you can
take the steps necessary to be a teacher
whether it's back in japan when that
opens up which i think will be sooner
rather than later
uh but but you got to get real serious
right now you got a good situation with
the parents
so now it's work work work work work pay
the debt off
yeah you 20 hours a week isn't your
answer 80 hours a week
is your answer and minimum wage is not
your answer um
so yeah go to the ken coleman website
kencoleman.com
or ramseysolutions.com ken coleman
and get a bunch of cans downloadable for
free tools
on getting hired and getting into a
different role uh you need to go make
some money kiddo
uh you you're you're living on nothing
you're starving for that
you have an income crisis